yes also previously won some games
against another back up just a tour of
at 18 years old you cash only 16 and
here we go here we go it's a queen's
Pawn opening from Abdul sotorov
yeah it was heartbreaking that much the
Olympiad kukesh left the tournament Hall
in tears it was just it was hard to hard
to watch and such high stakes but he'll
want revenge that all the top players
they're so competitive
what opening manual is kakash gonna
choose is he going to choose to go for
maybe a Queen's Gambit declined a nimso
Indian here we go he does push that
Central Pawn trying to bring the black
Bishop out
and uh yeah I mean both of these guys
they can play any opening Under the Sun
as well so hard to prepare for them
nowadays the youngsters
okay this is what we call the main
position where black has at least six or
seven
very viable moose
yeah I wonder whether the dark Square
Bishop will develop well whether we'll
see a challenge in the center with a
pawn
well I mean anything can happen really
you can see maybe even see magnus's
favorite move which is the to pick up
the a pawn and move it one square but no
he develops the bishop to its most
active point and pinning the Knight on
C3 yeah so no tarash no Vienna he
chooses the ragozin variation the
regosan defense
seen exchange of Pawns white starts
going Bishop okay comes out to this
Square this is very trendy recently it
does allow black to get active in the
center immediately kokesh doesn't
hesitate
but it does have a tricky reputation
okay Black's night coming out it leads
to very unorthodox players for far as I
remember this variation Magnus
experimented with it a year or so ago
with mixed results Black's night coming
out black is actually ready to start
pushing pawns on the king side this is
why Black's delaying castling his King
back is ready to push pawns to kick
White's dark Square Bishop away it's not
in the most secure Square
and okay white tonight retreating and
there we go oh it's Bishop Under Fire
immediately this one is already already
kind of against getting spicy nice an
exchange of pieces White's night takes
the Black Knight but which one is good
cash gonna take is he going to take the
white bishop or is he going to take the
white knight in the center you can
choose either
and uh just a really complicated
position already this last move from
Abdus tour of I think is not the most
popular yeah you're right about that
David no games in the database so if
suddenly there were loads yeah there
were loads of games after blacker pushed
this Pawn but uh yeah Magnus carlsening
is alireza farooja but no one absolutely
no one has captured that light in the
middle wow so relatively natural move
yeah but uh I guess everyone wants to
preserve their Bishop it's not just that
I think tactically it's awkward no
because if I played porn takes Bishop
now as black where do you put this
Knight because you have to move it
somewhere and on a move like Knight D2
can I just play Knight takes D4 I mean
it's you have to consider it a pawn is a
pawn as the old saying goes you're gonna
get an answer to your question Lawrence
yeah I mean and oh here comes the answer
it's a counter-attack against the dark
Square Bishop
yeah so uh leaving his Knight offer
grabs but counter attack this feels like
the type of thing I do Satora is
definitely prepared with computer the
evaluation bar might not say it's great
for white but maybe in order to get a
decent position black needs to find a
series of accurate moves modern
preparation
at its best and okay where's this bishop
going or do you just take the Knight
this is already difficult because it
would make sense to kind of drop back
with your Bishop
but now where's the White Knight going
guess the White Knight can also use the
square okay he doesn't go back no
retreating in this game
porn takes Knights porn takes Bishop
it's a weird Pawn structure it's only
move 11.
um these pawns these are doubled Pawns
just it's so hard to evaluate and uh go
cashing out the threat for white is to
take this Pawn also maybe to push a pawn
forward in the center to kick the Black
Knight away
is good cash gonna react by moving or
defending this Pawn or is he going to
react by maybe capturing the whiteboard
in the center
I mean it's so hard to evaluate already
I would be thinking of moves like
pushing this Pawn forward just to kind
of mess with White's development
uh I would also be thinking of just kind
of bringing the bishop out to protect
this Pawn but it's so concrete you need
to calculate a lot already yeah I
totally agree David speeders of the
essence here for good cash because
otherwise his King is going to be in
Dire Straits
David knuffler yeah
it has a song
our very own chess song I wasn't yeah
amazing
did you hear it Laura no I haven't heard
it all right we'll make sure to play it
once more yeah it's called the Poland's
lament it's very good yeah that song's
very appropriate right now I mean all
the pawns are just gonna drop yeah yeah
it's also weak it should be the song you
have when you walk into your chest
boxing fight can you I thought all
boxers they can choose the song I've got
I'm choosing between two songs I've got
two songs I'm not going to reveal it at
this moment I've got a dilemma and I've
also got to make sure because I don't
know how it works with copyrighted and
all of that stuff the last thing I want
to do is get sued
um but this is probably up to the
organizer and you'll probably have some
deal where they can use I hope so yeah
but this is a great question to ask yeah
Twitter to our audience yeah sure tweet
us what song should you have uh Lauren
feel free to shoot some tweets I am
should I have like a chess connection no
no no no no no no no I wanted to it has
to bring the energy it has to be an
energy song
um I've I've had a few ideas but I will
also was thinking about Norwegian tracks
and what does the fox say well that's a
good one I thought you know come out and
do a little fox impression yeah yeah
yeah I like that I wasn't expecting to
do that do you remember that song but I
didn't think that you would either
that'll really ruffle his feathers
all kinds of songs
um no feel free to tweet yeah good
boxing entrance yeah I would do
something by Celine Dion Celine Dion
It's a boxing match
not an anniversary
look at this position
what on Earth is this what's happening
David
um chaos Kaya just in one word it's
utter chaos right now black gave a check
white blocked it gave up appointment now
the white king is just running out into
the open and
is this white king gonna survive
it doesn't feel that way but cash
continuing developing his pieces Abdus
surely he's prepared this position look
at the clock times
um Abdus up over 15 minutes he's gained
time from when the game has started so
he must surely know what's going on and
I'm trying to do a quick count here
white has six pawns black has six pawns
it's a level material but it doesn't
feel that way it feels like someone's
sacrificed something and uh let's jump
in just to show what happened from the
last moment we were at the game it was
here we said this Pawn is on under
attack he needs to do something it did
commit did push forward it was captured
the black queen then jumped out the
white king is now on an open diagonal
white blocked it with a pawn and here I
mean I'm just surprised by every move
it's so hard to uh so hard to guess
there is a big threat along this
diagonal so the white king jumped out of
the way you couldn't take this Pawn uh
you couldn't remove the black one
because the Rook would fall to the black
queen so King D2 and Kakashi just
immediately reacts by bringing his
Bishop out it feels like the type of
position abdusator of thought he
surprised gokesh but maybe gokash has
actually studied this himself before
because he's played quite quickly too
black has such an easy next move he's
just going to Castle Queen side but
kokesh's moves have been very natural at
the same time right if you look at the
last three or four moves Bishop F5
cutting that King castles Queen side
comes a Tempo there are all kinds of
ideas here David Knight takes D4 is in
the air that just wins almost on the
spot yeah for example this Knight takes
D4 just wins takes takes check on F2 and
then Castle long and you pick up the
queen uh oh it's such as mate actually
excuse me it's just you forget the
coming yeah I mean this is I'll be
honest with you if norderbeck has
to prepare this and he hasn't gone
further than here then it shows a lack
of maturity in his preparation for
example you would never get somebody
like Fabi stopping here and not knowing
what to do he would already be very
clear because even though the computer
might say this is all right for white
from a human perspective this is
completely unplayable and gone can I
just add to that there's only one move
quite to survive this position
to develop the light squared Bishop to
G2 and what has it and what happens if I
Castle no sorry you want to take on C6
yeah that's the only move that remains
in the game everything else you're
looking at like something like a minus
three which is like a full piece
Advantage for black so he's he's on the
ropes he has to tread accurately now I
mean it still looks so scary for example
this bishop move Lawrence's idea is on
the cards I guess after 96 porn the idea
for white is that now you're the corners
defended maybe now you can play Pawn
text Pawn hitting the black queen and
black is not able to completely
coordinate it still looks scary I mean
the black queen could just drop back
actually over there there's only one
move as well so again you know you
cannot take the pawn as you highlighted
wow you can only go on the counter
attack so after Knight takes us after
the bishop develops so Knight takes the
pawn definitely the most critical try
white has to go on the counter attack
here and the only move once again to
remain in the game is to put the Knight
onto D5
and uh not obvious white going on the
attack against this Pawn but it looks
like you're you've got a leaking ship
and you're just trying to plug it no
plug the holes desperately but I mean
look at the white king look at the White
Queen if I were a human and seeing this
position for the first time I would just
think black's winning
um obviously the computer says no but
what a wild position
Breaking All the Rules as well don't try
this at home kids uh ever because you'll
get checkmated especially if you're
white but uh okay in the current
position
system move we're looking for and I
think you might be right Lawrence if he
hasn't played a move already it's been
four minutes now then he hasn't seen
this position before at least he hasn't
gone deeply enough
and yeah you can't Bluff your way at the
top level unfortunately I've tried I've
failed many times to Bluff my way
through complicated openings like this
one and so Bishop G2 the only move and
then potentially Knight D5 only move
yeah I mean it even gets even wackier
from there so I mean crazy crazy
position and uh well Nordy back is a
walking that tightrope and he's gone
into thoughts and he's thinking huh very
surprising as David and Lawrence have
pointed out
but it does mean that it's very exciting
for us especially for everyone watching
at home you know what a start to day two
yeah and uh someone I I do love it when
our viewers share with us their selfies
their pictures and I do have to give a
special shout out to Martin McKeon and
the dog and his dog Magnus oh who is
beyond year old today happy birthday
very happy that his namesake won the
first date yeah definitely a happy
birthday and we also have a question
from lofi now this is a cool question if
he asks us what would be your chess
inspired rap name
over to you guys
I'm very bad with this chess inspired
M.C howler I don't know MCO
MC Magnus crawls yeah exactly and I make
lots of howlers on the chessboard
meanwhile he hasn't talking of howlers
whoa Knight B5 thinking for five minutes
almost and then playing what could be a
losing blunder
um it makes some sense in a way it stops
that idea we mentioned uh that Lawrence
uh was suggesting sacrificing the Black
Knight in the center for White's pawns
opening things up why it's night is
going on the attack something similar to
what we saw earlier but
what's the refutation what is Black's
reply
the first move that comes to mind is
just castling Queen side for black
that was also my uh Instinct as well and
the position was so crazy that I just
had the engine running as well and it
says that one not so accurate okay black
also has to play some precise moves and
the most
um energetic move is actually to put the
bishop on e4 and attack The Rook wow
that that would show ice in the veins so
there's a threat of Knight takes born
and you just ignore it just plant your
Bishop in yeah Ivanka this one looks
incredibly strong you hit the rook in
the corner if the Rook moves then of
course the pawn just captures and black
is going to make a new Queen uh over the
next couple of moves so you kind of have
to just
let this Rook uh leave it to its fate so
Knight takes porn this is just one check
I guess the king will move
not even sure where but uh wherever the
king moves if the Knight takes the Rook
again I guess you just capture and
have you ever seen a physician like this
before
I mean I
probably something
kind of similar down the local coffee
house looks like yeah the junior a bit
under 12. yeah Junior Champions exactly
they're both Junior thirsty players oh
yeah they are as well yeah no but I mean
it's so rare to get such a random
position you know where both kings are
out in the open you have a weird Pawn
construction and uh look at Black's Pawn
on G3 getting ready to queen as well I
mean yeah G2 is a very cute uh Optical
move because it's very rare that you
have your Bishop in the corner blogged
in by your own Pomade that kind of
actually just almost wins
um it looks like we've set up the board
the wrong way around with it's like a
random chest but you put your Bishop in
white sun and White's cup and yeah I
mean it's
so weird right now if we go back to the
current position so this is the
strongest move we did see stockfish uh
suggest a few moves on our screen a
moment ago the second best move for
black also gives a big Advantage maybe
this is a more kind of natural human
move it's to drop the black queen back
uh just defending this Pawn no more
checks but also threatening to capture
this guy do you expect your cash to find
one of those two moves yes yeah yeah one
thing I've noticed about pregnant
is they are the master of
counter-attacks you know you attack
their piece and you think they're going
to move it nope they've uh they're so
good at just initiating a counter and uh
also calculating their way out of chaos
yeah and they're very disciplined these
young Indians because they have had
chess coaches from a young age they're
very disciplined with that calculation
so for instance I'm born in a position
like this one where uh Abdus just
brought his Knight forward
even if they're not thinking it directly
they will be looking at the checks
captures threats the forcing moves um so
for example we mentioned okay Castle in
Queen side reacts to the threats that's
decent too so this will be on his radar
but apart from that the two best moves
this one is a threat hitting the rook in
the corner this one is a threat hitting
this Pawn but it's also kind of a just a
defensive move so it's kind of Dual
Purpose and for sure those moves are on
the radar they'll just go one by one
they'll look at okay first this one if
it's not so convincing they'll look for
options then they might stumble across
putting the bishop in the court in the
center hitting this Rook okay he doesn't
find them though he doesn't find any of
those two moves he brings us Rook to the
center I I also thought that this was my
second move that I was because castling
on alongside you you feel as though you
put the king in a bit of danger so this
move also makes tons of sense because
after Knight takes C7 you can slide
across to f8 say yeah you want to pawn
so what now I'm prepared to go Knight
takes D4 on the next move and obliterate
you so I I didn't come up with this a
reason why this is such a bad move
clearly there is an issue though David
or Ivanka what is the issue with this
move
could could it be that um
there is no actual threat so you can
actually maybe develop the bishop to the
G2 Square now so we can't
uh we see a weird draw now yeah that's
yeah yeah you have the Knight takes Pawn
trying to blow up in the center
um maybe black has no more than a draw
it looks very scary for white still this
is Czech only one safe Square another
check only one safe Square I mean even
just taking this bishop looks very good
for black to be honest because the white
king is so naked out in the center
the problem is Black's King is also
Without Shelter yeah Lux King still has
castling rights you can still run away
when it's least expected but yeah I mean
it we can't blame gokesh for going for
this move if it were a classical game he
would have probably spent 20 30 minutes
on that one moment because it was so
critical and maybe he would have come up
with one of the computer suggestions but
this one looks very testing too so from
a human point of view very logical
um and I'll do a tour of still with some
issues to face the more I look at it the
more I hate it for white I've got to say
just looks like he's balancing on that
tightrope
again and
one slip you'll fall off you'll lose
immediately for white if black slips
okay the game is likely to go on so the
stakes are higher for Abdus due to his
King yeah and I'd like that tweet from
Jasper Vander or who says uh his blind
spots are so big but even glasses can't
fix them so I also quite like his handle
Jasper Jasper off
what's the best
what's the best uh handle you've come
across on the online platforms goodness
me there was a there was a quiz team at
the pub quiz the other day called the
knights who say knee man
yeah that's a good one
yeah just far off that's good I quite
liked Magnus cupson yeah Magnus cups
there's lots of puns on his name yeah
because like cagness
yeah
yeah chess fans are very creative they
are it was very nice when Magnus was
working together with his friend John
Ludwig hammer and they called each other
the MC Hammer very nice pretty yeah
that's
that works that works yeah and maybe MC
Hammer I should can't touch this yeah
there we go yeah that's uh that's a good
walk on tune yeah right oh that is that
is yeah I can see it lots of boxes have
nicknames right what would yours be oh I
do have a nickname it's going to be
announced it's
um
I wish uh no I I do have a name I'm
going to announce that next week I think
so that's that's sticking
um and I've got some more announcements
to make next week so uh keep your keep
your notifications on yeah
um so do people call you laws not really
not a few people do you know of some
some some friends but I'm not I'm not
going to go out there as laws I've got a
I've got a powerful name because I was
thinking yeah
no because you know uh the boxing names
tend to be a bit
um aggressive let's say you know the
dark destroyer was a Nigel Ben or
um you know uh all kinds of stuff like
that
no no it's gonna be it's gonna it's
gonna res it's gonna be good don't worry
all right we've got it all worked out
Lawrence um
you wanna go that far
more powerful
well the grind Master is what I like I'm
the grindmeister yeah talking about
grinding this is not a grind remember
that other game car that we looked at
that was more of a this is more they've
won yesterday no the one that we looked
at the first round today that was a bit
more grindy per nature I thought you
meant the 100 100 000 move game that we
finished off with you that is also a
grind yeah that's a real grind this is a
pure slug Fest this is them
you know just all-out War nice throwing
everything at each other we have to
admit that is the most entertaining even
if I know you like the long grain you
know this some players Kaya it depends
on your personality depends on your
style I commentate a lot with Peter on
the other channel Tanya does it as well
and I've commentated Peter gets so
excited over a little move you know just
a little idea within you save a little
bit of time or there's a little bit of
an improvement based on this position
and it fills in with such joy and I'm I
I mean I appreciate it because I'm a
chess player but I don't
you know get the same not the same sense
of elation that Peter gets I like stuff
like this you know I used to watch
Julian Hodgkin growing up shout out
Julian if you're there throwing his
pieces at his opponent and
yeah I'm from that school yeah yeah no
no Nuance no subtlety your caveman Simon
and I we we went to the same coffee
house as a kid no but I mean there's
Beauty a lot of Beauty in this of course
there is yeah will there be time trouble
because we're only at move 16 and go
cash and I was spending two minutes he's
down on seven minutes on the clock yeah
we can't blame the players for spending
so long because it is so critical so
early but
mean if we see a similar situation where
there's still so much chaos going on and
the players are down at one or two
minutes then we will see big mistakes
wow
um yeah right now it's enough time but
also you've got to make sure you don't
get checkmated
um so they will be burning that time on
the clock in the next few moves to me
I'm struggling to even come up with
alternatives to be honest to this idea
we just showed with um black going all
in and sacrificing
black would have a draw actually good
cash does have a draw in his pocket with
the variation we just showed maybe we
can jump back in and illustrate this one
more time so right now black black has
the move White's Bishop has just
developed so there's a couple of threats
for white
potentially one would be to remove this
Black Knight which is actually doing
quite a good job right now and the other
would be to just play Pawn takes Pawn
now that White's rook in the corner is
defended so time is of the essence and
just go all in I mean this is the first
move I would be calculating
now it takes porn it's been on the radar
for a long time again this sacrifice
this check the king drops back another
check and
here there's so many candidate moves one
move would be to just castle for example
for black trying to come and check the
white king maybe even Checkmate the
white king it looks dangerous no struck
me to come up with ideas here for white
to save it obviously you could calculate
taking this bishop off the board you can
calculate giving another check with the
black queen
perhaps so much uh to consider here you
could also just go back where you came
from with a check he doesn't play this
move well um it would have been too
tempting for me I would have wanted to
keep the draw in my in my pocket up my
sleeve because she doesn't go for all
these crazy sacrifices instead he just
drops his Queen back so this is a pin
and the threat is reinstated
but this does give white time yeah you
can now chop that night off can't you on
C6 Which Way Bishop most likely
um
rookies
which way do you take them interesting
you can sacrifice your Rook if you take
with a bishop phone takes the problem is
here your knight is attacked and if you
take with a rook for example
there's going to be this idea we showed
earlier
um here it's even stronger The Rook in
the corner and both the other Rook uh
they're both under Fire
they're forked
if you take for example this Pawn with a
check as you said earlier as well or
it's the king just moves and a threat of
Rook takes Pawn because due to this pin
that pawn is actually undefended
still so chaotic and the computer says
0.0 as if it's
as if it's nothing it's not it's not
easy and I I personally wouldn't even
think about capturing that night I mean
I think that the White's light Square
Bishop is so powerful and very much
needed as a Defender so I would be
tempted to defend the pawn sitting on D4
and maybe do some weird things like move
the Rook up the board yeah yeah and then
you can kind of go my King's getting
ready to run away if needed yeah you're
not running far because the bishop Cuts
you off
but uh I mean you could run this way
maybe you're right well yeah I have to
look after the E3 Pawn but yeah is that
it's there yeah so this would be a very
defensive move it feels shaky somehow
just this night is loose The Rook is
loose the bishop also undefended but I
know yeah sometimes you need to play
these types of moves
I mean it's not easy for Abdus at all
um the more I look at it the more I look
good Cash's option just from a human
point of view he's creating a threat and
Knight takes Pawn as we showed
and he's forcing abducator to burn time
oh I have a feeling it's going to be a
massive time scramble later and he seems
uh nervous subductor of he is just
moving a lot around in his chair making
his move he grabbed the phone
okay this is check Black's King will
most likely just Shuffle to the side
and the bar not liking it and my
instinct is also but it's not a good
move because the night was a valuable
defender of the D4 Pawn and now black is
threatening to just explode open the
position by capturing on the D4
yeah still the white king how do you
coordinate your army the white king is
in the way of the White Queen it's like
uh the bonecloud opening which is uh
famously bad but you put your white king
in front of your whole Army uh it
shouldn't be leading from the front of
the king it should be tucked away behind
and also your knight is far far away
from the rest of your pieces no
coordination there
how do you even stop this threat I mean
do you have to advance your Pawn forward
in the center for example just so that
now it's protected by the Knight would
this make some sense
still feels so loose
for example the Black Knight can just go
and grab a pawn the Black Knight isn't
yet actually threatened because the
white porn in the center is pinned
and this is the only move I even see to
stay alive for one more move let alone
for the rest of the game
it's still walking on that tightrope for
white it's empty Satora as well his last
move taking this Pawn check you have to
have a plan right you have to follow up
so you spent a long time on that and he
still hasn't moved
ticking down two three minutes on the
clock he lost the first round today of
this tutorial after that fantastic first
day in the tournament do you think he
will lose this game as well
looking very likely at least according
to the bar and just the momentum of the
game feels like it's in Black's favor
but we've seen turnarounds before in the
clash between these two
cash definitely won't take his eye off
the ball this time like he did at the
Olympiad
okay white did push in the center I
think that's the only way to stop
Black's threat
thing is though yukash is in his element
in this type of position you know it's
different when it's a classical game
where you have the time to think and
just invest and consider all your
resources now here you've got he's got
no time three minutes to navigate this
uh
this messy messy position I want to say
Quagmire it actually looks messy with
pieces it's horrible all over the place
I mean it's it's double pawns it's like
people have just kind of like gotten the
dice yeah and uh just shaking the chess
pieces all over the board I mean it's
the plus side for Abdul sotorov is that
uh kukash will also be a bit baffled by
this whole position as well but uh he is
the one attacking so that benefits him
yeah normally when it's a mess when it's
just a bit random it's all about King
safety and a material counts here the
material count is not really relevant uh
that white has an extra Pawn because
it's all about the king safety and
pieces and okay a natural move
we showed this one earlier actually in a
similar situation The Black Queen going
back now attacking the White Knight but
also attacking that white Pawn on B4 so
on the white uh on that diagonal at
least the white king is vulnerable so
would it help for a tutorial to just
move his King back because it must be
about getting that King to some safety
yeah I I that might be a very good move
Kyle oh nice yeah yeah I'm not sure why
I was surprised that sorry but uh it's
just because it's so weird this position
look I'm too satoroff
yeah this is this is just not a position
where you want two minutes and it's
because this is where if you've got this
yeah you need an hour and a half on the
clock to play it properly because it's
just impossible to be super precise here
there's too much going on too much
Mayhem
and uh Knight B5 and you can see the bar
now up close to plus three it's
basically saying with some accurate
moves here it's over for white and
understandably King is right in the
middle
pinned the pawns are horrible you're not
even really material up here as white I
mean um black go material right by just
grabbing a pawn yeah white has to block
with his Knight and then I'm not sure
it's the best move but you could take
another Pawn
with a check good now you'll move Kyle
dropping the king back is the best and
actually black has even if it goes to an
end game black has two past pawns for
later on black I'm not sure what you do
now do you put your knight in the center
of the ball to a nice Outpost do you
take this Pawn to kind of get this Rook
into the game activate it
back support up and with the attack I
think
yeah this is just uh
this is just gross
I mean maybe there's something even
stronger than that that's why gokesh is
thinking right now this is maybe a bit
too obvious
is something
more direct
and don't really see it maybe you could
take this Pawn with the Knight
okay you could take it this way he did
take with the queen check the White
Knight had to block
well he Feast on this one as well
very very one-sided right now okay it's
all under control but he's been in this
situation before two pawns up winning
position no counter play for a Boost
store and that one turned around yeah do
you think he is that that game from the
Olympiad is in the back of his head is
it hard for him not to think about that
devastating loss maybe not right now but
if if it continues then he can't wrap up
the win in a winning position I think it
would be human nature to get a bit
frustrated
to have those memories haunt him
Lawrence you're less uh you think yeah I
don't think the game from the Olympiad
is is on either of their minds I think
that's that's done now they've played
since and surely you've lost games
Lawrence where you want to get revenge
even years later
yeah against you
yeah
I remember no I've lost against you too
many times I can't really have I
actually ever beaten you I don't think
yeah you did did I yeah in 2002 I think
before NCL in a trumpovski I've landed
very early that was a long that was when
you were still in short pants I mean 11
12. yeah exactly I like how David
remembers everything every still trying
to get revenge for that one defeat
I thought yeah I've been David a few
times but then I was thinking about
actually I have never beaten David in a
classical game
yeah I actually forgot that I beat you
because it was so long ago
anyway anyways I feel old the king is on
E1 and uh
is it better there is it safer now at
least yes at least short term
the problem is White's best move would
be to Castle kingside right now but it's
illegal but then you can't move your
King again and okay yeah okay what's
Happening Here Yeah suddenly which pawns
are rolling oh no it has good cash
plundered again against update what is
this this move this is a beautiful check
maybe it's still
yeah if the Knight is captured okay we
have to show this um if the Knight is
captured now by the white Pawn
um this was the track then suddenly
Checkmate the king is not safe at all
the king is trapped this is a very nice
straight mating pattern if the Knight is
captured the other way which it was uh
then suddenly the white Rook drops the
white Rook has no more protection
and okay black is up what's the material
account a rook
white tonight but the white pawns are
very strong so it's not over yet huh the
threat against the bishop is there what
a tactic this was uh just just go back
to show it again night check this is why
we look for checks in every position
even if they look stupid because if they
work they can be very very strong uh you
give up your knight but you win the
white Rook because the night was
poisoned this is the current position
okay kakash I'm expecting him to retreat
his Bishop I'm not sure which way but
for example if he drops this bishop back
it is a bit scary that these pawns are
rolling he does drop the bishop back for
example the White Queen can step forward
hit this rook in the corner uh sometime
these pawns are gonna start latching he
is way down on the clock now cash yeah
yeah I'm actually worried for black you
meet me too I mean it's
for me it's like black sir Rook sitting
there on the h8 that's currently under
attack with the analysis position it
just doesn't have a role in the game
meanwhile uh White does have the
straightforward plan of playing Pawn
takes Pawn putting the king to finally
to a safe square and then just marching
forward with the pawns yeah actually
whites King's gonna be very safe there
finally yeah and black spawns actually
take a lot longer to March than whites
do in the center
three result game
with uh some time trouble coming up
taking down to two minutes now
abdulsator of he could be about to
become a huge Nemesis for gukesh if he's
able to win this game but it the bar is
still over to good cash side yeah but
it's the momentum in this position and
it was much further in his eye on his
side and he would have known he was
winning or at least close to winning and
yes he's up with material now but
he'll be feeling the pressure suddenly
the threats are against black
Rook has to move in the corner surely
what is he even thinking about I don't
know and uh meanwhile he's ticking down
to one minute
where's that black root going now
he has to be thinking about pushing
Harry
all the way over to age four I mean
that's the only way to liberate The Rook
but otherwise it's just a dead piece
yeah that black rock at the corner is
not a happy bunny
and uh yeah meanwhile Suddenly It's
autopilot for white right you just move
the white king off the back rank you
move the White Knight out once it's
unpinned
and that's yeah it's just you gain an
initiative it's all in White's favor
suddenly 45 seconds foreign
the only way this would end up as a draw
is if we see a lot of exchanges and
somehow for example black give up a rook
for some pawns and the game fizzle out
but it's much more likely we'll see
decided yeah and we see gukasha treat
the queen so he's very much planning to
push Harry the H porn all the way to H4
and just finally open some lines for his
works that's what he needs to do but at
the same time you know there's some
pawns up for grabs on the left side of
the board
yeah I would ignore this yeah yeah yeah
for now at least for now
okay kakash centralizes his Rook
the White Knight can come out now though
okay I guess maybe his idea is to put
the black queen in the center of the
board blockade the white Pawns
so hard to call I mean if you just gave
me this position without the evaluation
but I would have no ideas
I would quite like White's chances if
anything
but maybe I'm just influenced by the
previous uh previous position where
white was really
really struggling okay he does develop
his Knight the light comes out and I I
like your move of uh centralizing the
black queen and offering herself up for
a trade because you have to remember
black does have all the long-term trumps
in the position he has the better pieces
he also has these two amazing past pawns
over on the left top of Queens
good strategy normally and how about the
satoro well he even consider that
normally he would run away immediately
he wouldn't even consider trading Queens
but the problem is White's E4 Pawn is
also under attack so the pawn uh just
below the black queen if the White Queen
moves even if she goes and captures one
of the black pawns over there on the
left
suddenly things would fall so in the
current position uh the queen trade uh
if white avoids it this would
potentially walk into a just Bishop
takes Pawn keeping things simple and
suddenly things start to collapse a bit
for white uh suddenly there's checks in
the air as well the white king no longer
safe and you definitely don't want to
come under Fire in this position unless
The Rook couldn't move wow okay I'm
changing my mind with every move because
it's so complicated suddenly the white
Rook could attack the black queen and
the black queen looks perfectly placed
but actually the White Queen defends its
Knight and suddenly there's no checks
suddenly as well obviously the white
King was Under Fire suddenly the black
king is in danger Lawrence what do you
think in this position would you trade
or would you try and avoid uh
tough one intuitively I want to trade
but no uh I've just said sort of decides
to to just grab this Pawn as you were
analyzing very tricky position I mean
such a tricky game from start to
actually since around move eight of this
game it's been no moves have come easily
basically I haven't guessed any of them
yeah it's been a real mess but and three
results as David said this is this is
just
yeah if you gave this to me
and said who is better I legit wouldn't
be able to
I don't even know who I would take I
don't know I would say let's just go and
go down the good night and have a drink
and we'll discuss this another day and
watch this yeah we'll watch it yeah
exactly we'll have a meet-up or
something yeah very entertaining stuff
yeah and I I like what good cash has
done you know he hasn't forced Matters
by grabbing material instead he's just
moved forward with his King and finally
The Rook on age eight can uh finally see
the light of day
yeah it might be time soon before it's
too late yep he beat me to it to push
this pawn and uh you can at some point
even park behind it just to whoops uh my
arrows yeah just park behind it and
start
propelling it forward that looks
dangerous it's actually quite a hard
plan to stop uh White needs something
very Concrete in the meantime one thing
white could try for example is to try
and destabilize The Black Queen which
actually holds the position together
White's Knight could for example jump in
the black queen has to stay on this kind
of long diagonal because if she runs
away then suddenly the black King's
still in danger still some problems here
but okay he didn't go for this he tries
to keep an eye on the pawn instead Abdul
sotorov he's just trying to round up
this a straggler
and okay these ideas are actually in
action right now the black porn about to
push the White Knight harassing the
black queen
they're still I mean it's so chaotic
still this big material imbalance of
Rook for night and we have time trouble
you guys
pawns marching this poor marching Harry
finally joins the action and the bar is
over two hours yeah oh you're right
Lawrence The White Queen can sneak in if
you uh not there sorry it does sneak in
this way
um if you'd moved your knight then the
black queen would swoop back and win the
sport and black would be winning so
Queen E7 now a huge threat a huge trap
if the Knight is captured check and
checkmate
yeah and importantly if Queen deforger
you can just slow back with the Knight
93 and you have everything and D6 is a
lovely move here by uh after that sort
of just cutting The Rook you you hear uh
yeah and now 93 similar stuff big
trouble for gookash and it is one of
those Kai he's got to be careful not to
create the uh this kind of complex there
have been a number of instances in in
chess history where
you you know you just lose to the same
play it doesn't matter if you're winning
or if you're losing I mean good cash was
completely winning at some point he had
to find some precise moves now he's
Stone lost and pretty certain that I've
just said sort of will well when there's
lots of winning moves here
um the bishop will come in and join
Bishop D5 it is crushing yeah and a big
threat on the board of the queen
capturing the bishop so good cash has to
defend against that he moves his Rook
oh this is so bad I'm looking for Rook
text H5 is you also feel like you could
destabilize the position as well by
pushing forward the E Pawn but I quite
like your idea of just moving The Rook
um
yeah how about a queen White's porn
suggestion yeah both of those Central
pawns could push right now
um
spoil for choice plus 10 now on the on
the computer and yeah it's just yeah
this will come with experience for good
cash come with age but yeah it's just
pulling that handbrake when things were
turning against him
yeah there was a moment here to bail out
with Knight takes D4 actually was
actually maybe even after that though or
after that yeah but uh you'll move from
here style points yeah he's going for
the beauty price in this one uh if the
black Rook takes this white Rook then uh
the White Queen takes the bishop let's
show this could cash down to 10 seconds
meanwhile uh so this is really flashy
Rook takes pawn bishop takes Rook is
simply met by Queen takes and uh this
piece is pretty much trapped the black
king
no Defenders and uh in the current
position okay he does go for this but if
Rook takes Rook this was the flashy one
Queen takes Bishop check due to this pin
black king is doomed
so okay this is the current position on
the board now and how do you even defend
look at these they're cut off
wrong side of the board and it's over
there we go we have a result cash
resides oh no what a devastating result
for him he was winning this game against
Abdul sator of only a couple months
after losing a devastating game in the